here's what I'd like us to do I would
like you to consider I know you can work
this out immediately but I want you to
write it down with me consider four
times let's go with something like
fifteen okay now I wonder if you
remembered when you were doing you know
multiplication early on like in primary
school if you ever got shown that 4
times 15 you can think of it not just as
a number which by the way what is 4
times 15
it's just 60 right you can think of it
as a number but you can also think of
every multiplication between two things
you can also think of it as an area
here's what I'm gonna write it 4 times
15 is the same as 4 times 15 I'm gonna
break into a ten and a five I'm doing to
take the tens and I'm gonna take the
unit's out okay now what I'd love you to
do with me if you've got a ruler there
is can you draw for me
a rectangle that represents this for I'm
going to call this four units high and
then I'm going to go ten you can measure
that across and then I'm going to go
I'll just put some dots down there and
then I'm going to go another five so I'm
gonna call this ten and this five okay
so what I'm gonna form here is a couple
of rectangles it looks like so okay
now let's have a look at this together I
mean you already kind of know the answer
I'll show you why the answer is what it
is where my orange go
where did my orange it is okay if I
think of four times ten plus five I can
say it's kind of like the area of this
rectangle four times ten plus five okay
and so the whole rectangle kind of is in
two pieces can anyone tell me this
left-hand piece what's the area of this
side it's gonna be 40 right 4 times 10
is just length times breadth isn't it 40
and then you've got this other smaller
rectangle over here it's not 4 times 10
it's 4 times 5 which gives you an answer
of 20 which agrees with what we found
before right the total area 40 plus 20
gives you that 60 okay now this is nice
with numbers but we can extend it to
algebra because these pronumerals and
things we're dealing with they just kind
of stand in the place of numbers
for example if we said we had for a -3
I'm going to change it let's consider
the 4 with an A plus 3 instead it's a
little bit easier to conceive of if
everything's addition can you draw for
me the same rectangle but just we're
gonna label it differently same
rectangle but this time I'm gonna put
some different numbers on it I've got a
4 over here just like before but instead
of 10 and 5 which is what I had inside a
bracket before what shall I label on my
tops here a and 3 a and 3 now for anyone
who looked at those ones before the
expansion is still a bit funny and
confusing right can you see how this
gives us the two turns it's why I'm
distributing the 4 to the a and the
three what's the area of this part here
it's for a very good and then this
leftover part it's 4 times 3 which gives
you 12th a cube Bhairavi ok this is
nothing we know how to do this already
you're like I didn't need to draw a
diagram in order to know the answer to
these but I can use this diagram to help
me true your eye out some more
challenging things ok now see how we've
got some numbers here and then we've got
some algebra in the same way I want to
sixth in our numbers to be two-digit
okay so see how we've got four times 15
here I'm now going to try out 24 10 to
15 now you could you all did 4 times 15
just without without thinking right 24
toast 15 I think you could probably work
out with some time but it certainly
doesn't jump out at me what that answer
is immediately but I can use that same
model to help me out here you know how I
break apart the 15 into 10 and 5 I can
also break apart the 24 right it's well
how am I gonna break it out 20 and for
my tens in my units 20 plus 4 like so
okay and I can use this maybe you like I
just worked at the answer ray okay I'm
gonna confirm whether the answer is what
it is by drawing up another area Mon
another rectangle for myself okay this
one's gonna be a little bit taller now
so if I we've been trying to make it so
that the scale is reasonable it's gonna
start to get a bit harder here but I'm
going to
or across like so I've broken up my
rectangle into more pieces because I've
got 20 and 4 then I've got 10 and 5 is
this ringing bells for you you're like I
remember seeing this I can work out each
of those rectangles individually which
is much easier to do then doing the
whole thing 24 lots of 15 together so
100 time 20 times 10 what's this biggest
rectangle here 300 200 how about 20
there's 20 again times 5 it's gonna be
100 and then I've done those two so now
I do the bottom two which are actually I
kind of already did this before I'm
cheating by using easy numbers this is
still 4 times 10 so it's still 40 and
this is still 4 times 5 so that's still
20 and so the total shape is going to be
1 2 3 4 all added together can someone
tell me 360 very good so that's what 24
times 50 is equal to now I want you to
think about what that might look like
for something like this if it had not
just for lots of a plus 3 here's where
we're going what if I had say nothing on
the right hand side this guy here it's
got two bits to it two terms so we call
that we give it a special name it's
called a binomial you've seen buying
already just means to and Noble means
two terms okay so we're gonna try this a
plus 1 a plus 3 now this is new and this
is why we spent so much time developing
this to make sure we know what's going
on this is just like what we did here
right there's a binomial here two terms
binomial here two terms and I'm gonna
multiply this out so you can you draw a
nice big rectangle for me and we're
gonna work out all of the pieces
hmm okay now it actually doesn't matter
which one you make which but on this
vertical length over here I'm gonna make
that refer to this guy on the left hand
side okay so I've got two legs here
right one of them is gonna be a and the
other one's gonna be one so this height
here is a plus one following so far and
the width same deal a and then there's a
three so the whole width is a plus three
and now just like we did with the
numbers we can think about each
rectangle individually Russia can you
tell me what this rectangle he's gonna
be very good in fact it's not just a
rectangle it's a square because a by a
and make you tell me what this rectangle
over here is the thin one thin tall one
okay that's a little carefully you've
got a height of a right and I'm gonna
use that three but a cubed is something
else isn't it yeah it's gonna be three
multiplied by a so 3a is exactly right
okay how about Veronica can you tell me
what this lower wide rectangle is yeah a
it's just gonna be the one lot okay so
there's an a there and then I've got my
final little one in the corner you're
not cute to me what that one is three
very good now we got food and 60 by
adding up all four of these numbers here
I'm gonna do the same thing it was just
an algebra there right so here we go
a squared there's that one plus three a
there's that one plus a plus three
that's the whole shape can we write this
any simple we can write what are we
gonna do do it ah now now let's figure
out this we've seen this a cube cover a
few times right can someone tell me what
does ache it's an abbreviation right
what's X cubed and appreciation of
Krisher it's a cubed is about
multiplication a times a times a is
there any way here that we see a being
multiplied by itself three times
I see a multiply by itself twice I see a
three times a in just a single a but I
never see a times a times a so I'm gonna
leave it a cubed out of it okay
there is something else I can do with
these two in the middle though what
would you live in do there is yeah this
is called does anyone remember this it's
called collecting like terms these A's
in the middle there's three over here
one over there so that gives me four in
total does this make sense okay let me
try another one for you draw the diagram
for this instead of a plus one a plus
three I'd like you to try one that looks
like this now one of the weird things
about this unlike with our numbers is
that um you know twenty is going to be
roughly that much longer than four but
with a you're like I don't know what a
is a could be anything so you can draw
that to be a different length that
doesn't really matter all that much just
try and make it so it doesn't look too
weird and out of proportion I'm gonna
give you a minute to try and draw up
that rectangle think about what that
vertical knife will be what the
horizontal length will be and then we'll
have a look at the solution to go give
you back 30 seconds hello e it's time
you get all of the time it takes me to
rub this off and then write up the
answer and then we've all got to pack up
okay oops all right who's gonna help me
out with the first rectangle this one
the big one over here in the corner here
6a squared you know all that stuff we
spent time multiplying together so this
is what was for right Annabel can you
help me out with this rectangle over
here for and then the two a fantastic
well done perfect
Brava Joey he'll be done you three a and
lastly just a fault so this look there
it is is gonna be equal to I'm going to
add them all together the eccrine and
you have your question or a thought yeah
go ahead
now that happy times we just added them
all together